♪ (intro music) ♪
So, welcome to this episode
of TensorFlow Meets,
where I'm really delighted
to welcome Razial
straight from his talk
at the TensorFlow Dev Summit.
We spoke all about TensorFlow Lite.
Welcome, Raziel.
Can you tell us a little bit
about you and what you do?
Thank you.
I'm an Engineering Lead
at TensorFlow Lite.
I'm particularly focused
on model optimization,
which the goal is change
the models in certain ways
that can be smaller and faster
to execute in edge devices.
(Laurence) I see, okay.
Now, I have to say,
I geek out about TensorFlow Lite.
If I have a favorite thing
in TensorFlow, it's TF Lite.
I just love doing it,
the demos are always great.
When I do talks, it's usually about that.
So, it's really fun to have you here
to learn a little bit more.
Can you tell us what's going on
with TensorFlow Lite right now?
Yeah, we are doing a lot of things.
Like I said during the talk,
we're really trying to make
as easy as possible
to deploy machine learning on devices.
And this is really important
because machine learning
is moving from the server
to these edge devices.
And because of all
of these characteristics
that you have on the Edge,
it is challenging,
so we're trying
to make that very, very easy.
Now, on the flip side, it also means
that you have access to a lot of data,
it has a strong
privacy-preserving component.
So, really, you can build products
that otherwise wouldn't be possible
if you just rely on server-side execution.
So, the way I see our work
is we're enabling the next generation
of AI-based applications.
Now, to the people who may be familiar
with TensorFlow Lite,
they would think about it
as running on Android or iOS,
but you're also extending now
into IoT devices.
Yeah, we're extending to a lot of places.
The Google Assistant
is one example of that
where if you think the assistant
is running on Android,
is running on Google Home devices,
but it's also running
in many other types of wearables.
They're really trying
to push the boundaries
of where machine learning can execute.
So, we're trying to engage with them
and learn about those use cases,
and power those.
We also have this new project
about micro-controllers.
So, that's also very exciting
because we're pushing now
more to IoT devices.
Again, we're really trying to push
machine learning everywhere.
So, one of my favorite scenarios
of using it on a mobile device
was the Cassava-- if you've seen that.
Where it's like these plants in Tanzania,
and you can diagnose them for disease
by just waving your phone
over them like this.
So, it's just a really exciting scenario.
Do you see any other good, fun scenarios
around TensorFlow Lite
or maybe even using it
in embedded systems?
Yeah, like I said, one of the great things
of machine learning on the device
is that you also do away
with the requirements of connectivity.
This is very important
for many different countries--
the connectivity, perhaps,
comes at a challenge or is costly,
so we're trying to enable
all those things.
And, at the same time,
we're trying to support
more and more hardware
so you can execute better and larger
and more complex models on these devices
and do even more
exciting things with them.
Like, one example is the Edge TPU,
and that's something we're really excited
that we support it right now,
and we're working with them
to make it even better and even faster.
If you took a look at my presentation--
we have this very nice slide of MobileNet.
MobileNet is a very common
image recognition neural network,
and you can see the progress
from executing in floating point in CPU
which is the baseline to be able
to execute in CPU [quantized],
then with the GPU support that we have.
The GPU was already seven times faster
than what you can get from a regular CPU.
And if you look at the numbers
for the Edge TPU,
they're like over 60 times faster.
And this is really important
because the quality of the model
is very much directly related
to the size and the computation.
So, by enabling larger models,
then we can also enable better quality
- for the users.
- (Laurence) Excellent.
One of the things you were mentioning
there about particularly complex models,
like quantization and pruning.
Now, it used to be that was part
of the conversion process
when you're converting to TF Lite,
but now you can do it beforehand?
Yes, we can do it before
and we can do it after.
Each one has its pros and cons.
The nice thing of beforehand
is that you can get even better quality.
So, typically,
with all of these techniques,
you have a model,
and you apply one of these techniques,
and it might affect
your accuracy a little bit.
So, by doing it at training time,
we're really trying to minimize that loss,
and in many cases, there is none.
Now, the nice thing is also
that being part of the TensorFlow,
we have also Keras
as this really nice abstraction
for neural network layers.
So, we're building on top of Keras,
and if you look at other APIs
that are coming very soon,
it's extremely easy for anybody to just--
if they have already a Keras model,
it's very easy to apply
quantization and pruning.
At the same time,
we're making a huge effort
also on the post-training side
to make it very easy for everybody
to also quantize a model, for example.
And that's because some people
are not very familiar with training
or the first thing they want to try
is to just have a model
that they got somewhere
and they want to quantize it.
So, that's why we have this other path
of doing post-training quantization.
So, we're very invested in doing both,
like power users
and somebody that just wants to try it
and see how things go.
That makes perfect sense.
So, if somebody is really inspired by this
and wants to give it a try,
how would you recommend
they get started?
Well, we have a lot of sites,
a lot of examples
in the tensorflow.org site.
We have right now
four completed applications
that people can try.
And we're trying to really build up
our model repository.
And the goal is that
if there is somebody out there
that perhaps doesn't have the experience
or doesn't want to invest right away
but has a cool idea
for a very interesting product,
they can go to our repository,
see what is there,
and maybe there is something already
that they can take advantage of.
And maybe they can build
on that and expand
and others can learn
from their experience.
Yeah, exactly.
I think it's all about
making friction-less adoption.
Like, once you feel comfortable
doing something,
then you can try more complex things,
and more complex things.
So, thanks so much, Raziel.
That was, as always,
informative and inspiring.
- Thank you.
- So, thanks, everybody
for watching this episode
of TensorFlow Meets.
If you have any questions for me
or any questions for Raziel,
please leave them in the comments below.
And I'll also put a link to his talk
from the TensorFlow Developer Summit,
so you can learn a lot more
about TensorFlow Lite.
So, thank you so much.
♪ (ending music) ♪